mr. Joseph young of Africa impressive
remember how mightyjoyoung waved goodbye
another big one Oh audience hits joke
with Patriot alright you know during the
commercial I was thinking about the
first movie that I ever saw and it was a
home movie it was done in 1956
8-millimeter real shaky backyard family
barbecue my dad was at the camera my
uncle Danny was at the grill you know
those old home movies that always look
like this
my whole family was there my uncle Danny
my aunt Verity my mother and the funny
thing was Brian Dennehy was in it that's
good all right got you back to present
Ron I'm sorry to keep you waiting you
like this okay to present the next two
awards a woman who fought off gremlins
one and two a man who fought for the law
and the law won in reversal of fortune
he's a Tony Award winner as well here is
Phoebe Cates and Ron silver
the category of Best Documentary Feature
length has been an important part of the
ostrich a tradition for over 50 years
it's not as sexy perhaps as a Best
Picture or Best Director but still it's
one of the most beloved and
anxiety-producing categories at Oscar
parties throughout the country because
as we all know whoever gets this one
right inevitably goes on to win the pool
okay so pencils ready America the
nominees are American dream Barbara
Kopple and author Cohn produces Berkeley
in the 60s mark Kitchel producer
building bombs mock Morrie and Susan
Robinson produces forever activists
stories from the veterans of the Abraham
Lincoln Brigade Judith Montel producer
Waldo's sold a screenwriters attorney
Robert Hillman and Eugene core produces
and the Oscar for feature-length
documentary goes to American Dream
Barbara Kopple
dear friends of the Academy I take great
pride to accept the Academy's
recognition of our work together I want
you to know that only in America in a
free democracy like America would it
have been possible to make a film like
American dream and I feel today more
than ever the free world owes America
the United States of America deep
respect and everlasting gratitude
Barbara thanks yes I'd like to honor all
the other documentarians because their
work was so remarkable I'd like to thank
my parents my son Nicholas and Eugene
Carroll for all their support and love
the editors of the film
Larry silk Tom hanneke Kathy Kathleen
the cameraman Kevin Keating Hart Perry
Peter Gilbert and I'd like to dedicate
this film to the people of the Midwest
and the families and the meat packers in
Austin Minnesota whose American Dream is
so precious and so vital and they went
out on strike for their slice of the
American Dream and were permanently
replaced and lastly for James Michael
Carroll whose life was so violently
interrupted he will be deeply missed
in the category of documentary Short
subject the subjects are long on variety
these are the five nominees who so
successfully use this compressed form to
express their ideas burning down
tomorrow
Kip Thomas producer chimps so like us
Karen Goodman
and Kirk Simon producers days of waiting
Stephen Okazaki producer
journey into life the world of the
unborn Derrick drama producer
Rose Kennedy a life to remember Rita Lee
mock and Terry Sanders producers and the
Oscar goes to days of waiting Stephen
Okazaki producer
I didn't trip I'd like to thank the
corporation for public broadcasting in
the Wallach Wallace Alexander de Bodhi
foundation for funding me like to thank
Cheryl Yoshioka and bacon socket on e
for working on the film I'd like to
thank my friends and family particularly
my other father for their support and
I'd like to dedicate this to Stella
Ichigo who devoted her life to fighting
racism thank you
one of the real thrills of this job is
to get to introduce people like our next
presenter when I saw him backstage he
said to me are you introducing me are
you introducing me are you introducing
me are you introducing me are you
introducing me are you introducing me
I'm talking to you are you introducing
me can you hear me I think you can hear
me are you introducing me don't look at
me that way are you introducing me he's
a tremendous actor he has been a taxi
driver a deer hunter a king of comedy
and a Raging Bull all parts my agent
turned down for me
ladies and gentlemen five-time nominee
two-time Oscar winner a real hero for me
Robert De Niro
a colorful colorful tapestry of frontier
history is the third of this year's Best
Picture nominations it's a story of how
Native Americans struggled fiercely to
survive a romantic white soldier joins
the dignified Sioux as they battled
their enemies unfriendly tribes the
Union Army white settlers and harsh
winters Dances with Wolves